eh bien il est l'heure de retourner à
châteauroux retrouver patrick qui va
nous parler de la région ben oui vous
avez pris vos habitudes avec nous
antoine comme chaque jour on va profiter
du passage du au tour de france pour
faire le tour de la france
aujourd'hui nous sommes à châteauroux
donc dans l'indre d'huile qu'on va un
peu mieux comme être ensemble vous en
découvrez les premières images
une chose que vous ne savez peut-être
pas c'est que châteauroux est la
troisième ville la plus sportive de
france il ya un classement établi comme
ça chaque année nous allons découvrir
châteauroux à travers le portrait d'un
de ses habitants un castelroussin
c'est comme ça que l'on dit il est à la
fois capitaine de l'équipe locale de
water-polo
il fait également du triathlète il a
séduit plus près ce pot et frédéric
dollars à châteauroux il ya un étang il
n'y a pas de maire il ya des vagues
celle de la piscine belle île et même
une équipe de water polo en national
s'il vous plaît
les enfants de neptune loyter cole est
une discipline née d'un esprit tortueux
les efforts du handball dans la
pesanteur du milieu aquatique un sport
très intense les matchs durent
relativement longtemps
durant une heure et quart et une heure
et demie et on a très peu de temps de
récupération on a ça se compose de
quatre périodes et on a deux minutes de
récupération entre conséquence évidente
même en eau trouble pas une once de
graisse et le capitaine est
superstitieux sans numéro 13 points de
victoire mais il accepte les équipes de
mixte nous intervenons à châteauroux
existe il faut le signaler depuis 1922
quand même un sport qui est présent
siens ont nagé dans la rivière dans
l'indre criton depuis l'âge de 7 ans
bruno a abordé récemment le triathlon
natation 500 m une promenade pour lui la
course à pied et le vélo un kilomètre
qui lui permet à l'entraînement de
redécouvrir les rues paisibles de
château il ne faut pas trop se fier à
cette inquiétude parmi les
castelroussins célèbre il ya 60 ans une
dompteuse qui fit poser un dentier en or
à son lion celui-ci sortie de
l'anesthésique si un véritable carnage
et dû être abattu le fonds va finir
côtelettes dans un restaurant de la
ville dernière discipline triathlon la
plus dure pour bruno 5 km de course
il préfère s'entraîner en compagnie du
monsieur sport de châteauroux
michel lacôme est fier d'appartenir à la
troisième ville la plus sportive de
france 137 associations sportives on
peut pratiquer 50 de discipline on n'est
pas d'amendé soir traditionnelles on
peut trouvé à châteauroux certaines
formes de pratiques telles que le roller
le skate puisque nous avons un club à
châteauroux qui possède une salle indoor
il ya également le tir à l'arc qui a
également beaucoup de licenciés et on
retrouve aussi discipline peu connue
mais qui qui prend forme à savoir le
football américain
en tout douze mille cinq cents licenciés
sans compter les amateurs dominicaux de
la gaule